[Music]
on this Wednesday night a childhood
dream turns to tragedy this is a man who
at five years old decided he wanted to
be a police officer the rookie Ontario
officer gunned down on his first solo
ship
no way home now I'm getting frustrated
Canadian Travelers seemingly abandoned
by their Airline and this year's top
news stories nobody really expected
anything like that to happen what really
captured the attention of Canadians
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Chris gayles
good evening and thanks very much for
joining us Ontario Provincial Police
have charged a 25 year old man and a
30-year-old woman with first degree
murder in the shocking death of a rookie
OPP officer Constable Greg Pierce
shallow was shot and killed while
responding to a call about a vehicle in
a ditch the 28 year old was on his first
day of solo Patrol after completing his
10-month probation Global Sean O'Shea
has the latest heartbreaking details
Sean
Chris this is the fifth Canadian police
officer to die in the line of duty this
year the officer who died Tuesday
evening had just barely passed probation
he was only 28 years old and had spent
less than a year on the job Ontario
Provincial Police Constable Greg
percella originally from Barry Ontario
described by the head of the force as
someone who knew early on exactly what
he wanted this is a man who at five
years old decided he wanted to be a
police officer and he had a brief
opportunity to live out his dream and to
do his best to keep our community safe
Priscilla was responding to a call in
rural Ontario about 40 kilometers from
the city of Hamilton Police say the call
was about this car in a ditch the
officer approached the motor vehicle and
the information we have is that it was
open fired upon and he was shot and
killed the local community was told to
stay indoors as police sought suspects a
few hours later they arrested 25 year
old Randall McKenzie and both suspects
face first degree murder charges the
meeting with the family was extremely
devastated they are absolutely
heartbroken within hours of the officers
death tributes poured in Ontario Premier
Doug Ford Rochelle was killed while
honoring his oath to protect his
Province prime minister Justin Trudeau
said the thoughts of all Canadians are
with his family
Rochelle's body was taken into
procession to the coroner's office
escorted by police officers and other
First Responders with five Canadian
police officers killed in the line of
duty in 2022 police funerals are met as
a reminder of the wrist faced by law
enforcement priscella had been a special
Constable working at the Ontario
legislature before joining the force
he'd served in the Canadian Armed Forces
and had been a competitive wrestler in
University then on the very day he was
told he passed a mandatory 10-month
probation and was allowed to work alone
he was shot and killed while on patrol
by himself everybody commented about
what a fantastic police officer Greg was
focused now besides the investigation to
support his family his parents and
siblings Chris all right Sean thank you
that's Shawn O'Shea and Cayuga Ontario
tonight now Canada's Transportation
Minister says he's concerned thousands
of Canadians are still stuck abroad
after their flights were canceled
multiple times Following last week's
winter storm many any passengers claim
they've had little to no communication
from sun wing Airlines for days and
still don't know when they'll be able to
get home nitu garcha reports
today is no flight going back home
for hundreds of Canadians stranded in
Puerto Vallarta this is the message
they've repeatedly heard from sun wing
representatives for sameen Banji who
recorded this video it was the fifth
time in a week she thought she was going
home to Vancouver with her family we can
understand the weather but the weather
maybe was two or three days delay well
I'm on day seven I mean on day 14 of a
seven day trip like there's no what the
way they can be blaming weather right
now so this is actually where the dinner
and reception area is going to be Allen
Indiana are more than five days into
their trip from Toronto to Cuba to get
married and they still don't have their
baggage we're all sitting down here with
no luggage uh no wedding attire or
wedding decorations they say they flew
with sun wing and have gotten few
answers from the company now I'm getting
frustrated and I'm getting angry because
there's no this is not necessary
Canada's transport minister is calling
the situation unacceptable in a tweet he
says Canadians are patient when it comes
to weather disruptions but they rightly
expect their Airlines to keep them
informed and to manage these disruptions
smoothly sunwink said this week its
return flights continue to be delayed
due to displaced crew and aircraft from
the aftermath of severe weather
disruptions across Canada there's been
no measurable Snowden
it's been just so stressful I've been on
the phone every day with Sunwing in a
statement the Canadian Transportation
agency said it won't comment on this
issue because it has all the powers of a
superior court and Sunwing situation may
come to be decided by our tribunal and
passengers who believe an airline didn't
follow the air passenger protection
regulations can file a complaint for
potential compensation and refunds
they're not living up to what they're
saying that they're doing they could sit
here and say they're sending all these
rescue flights to only two rescue
flights that come this week so clearly
they're not doing their job Banji says
she hopes Sunwing will be held
accountable and improve its
communication with customers who feel
abandoned by the airline
Global News
in the U.S no Community was hit harder
by deadly winter storms than the Buffalo
New York area where the death toll has
now risen to 34. a massive blizzard over
the holiday weekend dumped more than
four feet of snow on parts of the state
with the City of Buffalo getting the
worst of it authorities say at least
three of the Dead have still not been
identified and there are concerns the
death toll will rise as the full extent
of damage becomes clearer members of the
National Guard have been called in to
help clean up and they are going door to
door in some neighborhoods to check on
residents in total at least 60 deaths
have been attributed to the storm across
the U.S as China continues to loosen
pandemic related restrictions other
countries are imposing restrictions on
those traveling out of China China
recently announced an end to its zero
covid policy followed by a surge in
cases the U.S Italy India Japan and
Malaysia will now all require Chinese
travelers to submit negative tests for
entry so far Canada has not followed
suit China's official death toll this
week stands at three however
International bodies studying the virus
say it's more likely to be in the
thousands that comes at the end of a
turbulent year for airports and Airlines
across the world as passenger numbers
bounced back the industry really
struggled Redmond Shannon has a look at
the challenges facing Airlines and what
passengers should expect in the year
ahead
on Wednesday Hong Kong followed China
its government says it will scrap most
covid-19 restrictions for incoming
Travelers despite other countries now
placing new testing rules on travelers
from China 2022 was a year when
restrictions mostly fell away across the
globe the resulting Rebound in air
travel was almost as sharp as the fall
off in 2020 although still about a third
below 2019 levels the number of air
Journeys is back to where they were in
about 2014. it's no longer the case that
we are convincing passengers to try to
fly more to get back to where we used to
be in aviation it's just whether or not
airlines are in a position to be able to
do so and that was the Rob Airlines and
airports that quickly laid off staff in
2020 struggled to hire back enough
workers to meet demand resulting in
travel nightmares I got stranded in
Montreal for over for 24 hours I had six
cancellations six delays for money 2022
will be remembered as the summer of last
luggage and not just in Canada London's
Heathrow Airport desperately asked
Airlines to Simply sell fewer tickets
the invasion of Ukraine disrupted
aviation in Europe Ukraine's airspace
unsafe Russia the world's largest
country banned Western Airlines from
flying through its Skies too the cost of
oil dropped back after a post-invasion
spike but price hedging means there's
often a delay in how that affects ticket
prices the cost of air travel make no
mistake over the next year is going to
be higher than that of 2022 and it will
be attributed mostly to the war in
Ukraine and what that has done to the
oil price as flying continues to Rebound
in 2023 the looming headache for
Airlines will be squaring that growth
with the industry's ambitious net zero
emissions targets Redmond Shannon Global
News London
a jail guard has been suspended
following the death of an inmate at a
Montreal detention center after the
inmate was allegedly injured on
Christmas Eve 21-year-old niku de Andres
spring is said to have succumbed to his
injuries after being transported to
hospital from Montreal's Bordeaux jail
Quebec Provincial Police have launched
an investigation into the incident but
no information has been released about
how spring was injured only that an
autopsy will determine the cause and
circumstances of his death people who
knew the man planned to hold a vigil in
his honor Friday evening
a former Nazi concentration camp
secretary gears up for a new legal
battle coming up why this 97 year old is
not going away quietly plus escaping the
war the resulting Refugee crisis from
Russia's invasion of Ukraine
[Music]
residents in Hassan are being urged to
leave the recently liberated City in
Ukraine with Russia intensifying its
assault on the region a maternity
hospital is among the dozens of Civilian
targets hit in Wednesday's strikes
although mothers and their newborn
babies were taken to shelter safely the
building suffered significant damage
City officials say harsan is one of the
most dangerous places to be right now
but say that they are having difficulty
convincing residents to leave a strike
on Christmas Eve killed at least 10
people
there are estimates about a hundred
thousand Ukrainian soldiers and an equal
number of Russian soldiers have been
killed or injured since the start of the
war in February caught in the middle of
the fighting are those civilians tens of
thousands have been killed Millions had
to leave their homes and tonight Mike
Armstrong takes a look at what became
the biggest Refugee crisis in Europe
since the Second World War
comings continue so does the misery
just over the last month according to
the U.N close to 700 000 ukrainians have
been forced out of their homes
summer there were actually more refugees
re-entering the country than leaving
that's turned around again and experts
say likely to get worse people who had
been holding out with winter Now setting
in may have to give up if there is
widespread power outages and you know
Sub-Zero temperatures there's just not a
possibility for people to stay
the numbers are staggering inside
Ukraine an estimated 5.9 million people
are displaced the number forced out of
the country is even bigger more than 7.8
million fled to Europe Canada's
contribution 132
000 refugees were brought to this
country the reaction was quick and
bipartisan although uneven different
provinces have decided to do different
things so you know some of the Maritime
Provinces have been very proactive
um you know even chartering planes and
getting people to Canada other provinces
have been a little bit like well if they
come will deal with it in the first
weeks of the war there was a rush to get
out about 200 000 people were leaving
every day we were on the ground in
Poland and Western Ukraine most of the
people we met didn't know where they
were going only that they couldn't stay
This Girl's family said they were
waiting for a bus they didn't know the
destination they did know it was better
than being at home
she says she and her family spent five
nights hiding in their basement
now with that sense of urgency the
European Union dropped the regular
Asylum system and granted ukrainians
temporary protected status the candidate
was called temporary residence status it
gave displaced ukrainians immediately
Access to Health Care education and the
ability to work Refugee Advocates have
praised the reaction but also pointed
out how different it is from the way
refugees from the Middle East and Africa
have been treated years it stands out
because it is in Stark relief to the
welcome or lack thereof for people from
other places and even frankly for people
who were in Ukraine from other countries
so
um African students or International
students from elsewhere who were
racialized who are studying in Ukraine
and when they went across the border
we're told no no this is for ukrainians
now there are challenges ahead for the
millions of ukrainians outside their
country conflict ends do they try to
stay where they've settled or try to go
home and if they choose to return then
there's the question of what are they
going back to
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal
in the U.S the Supreme Court has voted
to keep a controversial immigration
policy in place for at least another six
months known as title 42 it allows the
government to turn away Asylum Seekers
from the U.S Mexico border
news of the decision was met with
protests from migrants in El Paso Texas
the policy was invoked in March 2020 by
then president Donald Trump during the
early stages of the pandemic it was set
to expire on December 21st but the
Supreme Court blocked its termination
and extended the policy after a narrow
5-4 vote President Joe Biden says his
government will comply with the ruling
but told reporters he believes a reform
is long overdue
a 97 year old German woman is appealing
her conviction of being an accessory to
murder during her time as his secretary
at a Nazi concentration camp more than
75 years ago dubbed the Secretary of
Evil by German media ERM guard ferkner
was found guilty of being an accessory
to more than ten thousand murders
earlier this month the court handed her
a two-year suspended sentence saying
ferkner willingly supported the cruel
death of prisoners during the second
world war it's not yet known when the
court will consider her appeal
Pope Francis is urging the public to
pray for former Pope Benedict saying he
is very sick the pontiff didn't reveal
the nature of Benedict's Illness but
during his Wednesday audience he said
quote let's ask the Lord to comfort him
and support him in this testimony of
love for the church until the end the
Vatican confirms Benedict's health is
worsening due to Advanced age Benedict
whose 95 has been living at the Vatican
since he retired in 2013. he's the first
pope in some 600 years to resign the
Vatican has detailed procedures to
follow when a pope dies but hasn't
published any rules for a pope emeritus
inflation mitigation just ahead the
potential side effects of government
giving financial support to struggling
Canadians
[Music]
questions tonight about how much help
from the government is too much help
governments of all Strife across Canada
are providing financial assistance to
taxpayers as a way of easing The Sting
of inflation but as Ross Lord reports
cost of living checks could come with
some unintended effects
inflation that reached record levels
this year put immense pressure on all
levels of government to offset the
impacts most provinces and territories
are providing inflation assistance cost
of living payments that largely are in
the hundreds of dollars per recipient
among the more generous is Newfoundland
and Labrador the cost of food has risen
dramatic dramatically so what we've been
able to do now is provide an extra five
hundred dollars that people can utilize
um you know either for their heating
costs or for food costs the checks are
costing the province almost 200 million
dollars it has the money because one
inflation driver the high price of oil
generates big bucks for the government
across the rest of the country that
price tag is almost 7 Billion Dollars
policy analysts say cost of living
relief checks fall far short of
offsetting the impact of higher prices
although they could boost morale most
people feel some sort of crunch between
December January February worry when
everybody's kind of trying to do a bit
more around the holidays and now
people's money isn't going as far as it
used to anyway and so it could be that a
even a small piece of relief right now
is very much appreciated especially with
things like food prices forecast to keep
increasing but government intervention
might be hitting its limit Newfoundland
and Labrador calls its inflation checks
a one-time measure hoping more mail outs
won't be required we're not finished our
budget by any stretch of the imagination
at this point so we'll we're watching as
to what's happening hopefully things
will start to ease with many Canadians
looking for a break from inflation and
the elected officials looking to help
where they can where the spending train
comes to a stop will be a big question
in the new year
Ross Lorde Global News Halifax
[Music]
here next what Canadians think is 2022's
top story
[Music]
as 2022 draws to a close Canadians are
reflecting on the major events that have
shaped this year a new ipsos poll
conducted on behalf of global news finds
some major conflicts for front and
center for a lot of people tariya
Israeli explores the top news stories of
2022 according to you
streets sliced open by shrapnel scorched
Vehicles bombed out buildings the
Ukrainian Army retook the southern city
of kirstan from Russia but it Bears the
wounds of battle as does the entire
country in a conflict that's reshaping
both Europe and the world and leaving
its mark on the year 2022. nobody really
expected anything like that to happen in
Europe it's been what 75 years or so
since the last war an epsos poll done
for Global News found more than 70
percent of Canadians believe the war in
Ukraine is the biggest international
news story of the year just saw the uh
the president of of Ukraine and
Washington
um you know it's it's clearly you know
front page news and people are paying
attention this defense expert predicts
they will have to keep paying attention
because this will be a protracted War
Russia knows it would probably be
playing the long game so the question is
uh is NATO going to remain as cohesive
as they sounded in 2022.
concerned about conflict abroad they
were also focused on economic
uncertainty at home and the rising cost
of living
40 percent of Canadians consider Rising
interest rates and inflation the second
biggest International Story the war in
Ukraine is helping drive up energy costs
while the pandemic keeps disrupting
Supply chains all these factors have
fueled record food prices these macro
events became very micro meaning they
hit everybody personally and
individually the freedom Convoy that
took over Ottawa also dominated the
conversation 62 percent of Canadians
consider it the top domestic story
economists believe Financial fear is the
theme of 2022 and what connects all
these headlines yeah I think inflation
has plateaued and what we're going to
see are gradual keyword is gradual slow
declines in inflation the top stories of
2022 that will shape the next year terea
isri Global News
Ottawa
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Chris gayles tonight's
York Canada is blumenort Manitoba just
southeast of Winnipeg and we love seeing
your Canada so please email your
pictures to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks very much for
watching hope to see you again right
here tomorrow have a great evening
foreign